here have a spirit sticker don't be the
only student without one
i actually go to this school
wow you really are invisible huh i could
not be more fine with it you're like
that guy from that movie who wishes he
was never born
it's a wonderful life you say that but
do you mean it
beautiful day here at red stag field
kicking off from the home team is number
44 jason miller who also plays lacrosse
soccer
and all the girl parts when he and his
friends act out high school musical
quite possibly the only girl parts he'll
ever see
haley
hey dylan
i didn't realize you were coming here
are you kidding this place is like a
home to me it's like i was schooled but
i wasn't i was school school
were you
i got six kinds of pills in my pocket
but this here all this
this is the best medicine oh i'm glad
you're feeling better
so charlie
[Music]
i'm here to get lily before i call her
we had a small issue today one of the
boys patrick said lily pushed him down
and tried to kiss him now that doesn't
sound like lily she was probably
imitating something she saw on tv or in
her family no it was the tv yes
but here she is she's always so sweet
bye patrick you see they're just friends
what are you laughing at evan you're
next
okay i'm going to talk to her for a
little bit
oh did i ever tell you that i put your
name up here
haley dunphy dome oh you never special
spot actually it was supposed to be
haley dunphy doomy
i'm bad with spacing
oh
you're not so bad
and that's halftime panther six dolphin
zero that zero scored by jason miller
who proudly prances off the field just
let me go up there and kick that kid's
butt knock it off miller i need your leg
take a knee
now i don't know what tuna net you
dolphin swam into but you are drowning
out there coach would it really be such
a bad thing if you lost beg your pardon
look at them coach haven't they lost
enough already maybe giving them a win
would in a way be a victory for us too
okay you know what mattered to most
coach tonight his work was special needs
kids okay he took one kid to one beach
one time football football is what
mattered the most he lived for
competition he believed in sportsmanship
integrity
okay now the way i see it we can roll
over and give them an empty meaningless
victory that he would hate
or we can go out there leave it all on
the field
and be a team he would be proud to lose
to
now is this an eye activity or a wii
activity we what wait
[Applause]
hey tim
yeah the next three days of delivery
slips for you here signed huh thanks
claire yeah uh sign those up good huh
yeah thanks so this is this is the uh
the regency birch beautiful model
gorgeous you guys do such good work down
here
really you mind if i take her for a spin
before she goes up to the showroom
you're the boss his daughter yeah that's
what you want to say
oh okay so
so no mirror when they're shipping which
makes sense
i also have a
no handles
hey hey tim
hey tim
tim
oh god
yeah hi dad hey co-worker just seeing
when you want to leave for the game
we're late already so
soon
i'm i'm just i'm finishing up a little
paperwork in my office okay
let me know if you need any help no i do
not need your help and as i believe
i mentioned i would appreciate it if you
were not constantly looking over my
shoulder come on give me some credit
that's the last thing i would do dad you
seem to forget that i raised three
children and i had
a career before this i have done plenty
of stuff that does not
do you hear that sounds like it's coming
from the warehouse yeah what even is
that
oh i'm sure it's nothing
uh
one piece of advice take it or leave it
what
the latch is under the panel on the
right
hey
[Music]
you